so big big news from facebook this week
they announced Facebook home for android
which is sort of like a nappy skinny
thing yes they also announced a new
phone this piece of hardware it's going
to be running it out of the box but we
could talk about that later first why
don't you take us through facebook home
for Android and what it is what it does
and why you want it yes so Facebook home
like you said it's kind of like an OS
skin a bit it's it's not it's not quite
an operating system it's not quite a nap
but the biggest thing is that it takes
control of your lock screen in your home
screen so the first thing you get when
you pick up your device is Facebook your
facebook notifications are just right
there so like when I when I hit the
power button it pops up and instead of
seeing like the clock and the weather
and all that it just has yeah what you
know my mom's photo of her breakfast or
something yeah your mom's heart of your
breakfast you know that person from high
school that went on some rants well you
know all of that right there it's
fantastic you know if you like Facebook
it's it's fantastic which is you know
kind of the main thing if uh you know
it's it's Facebook all right there on
your device so it's basically like the
newsfeed thing you can just sort of flu
yeah it's a my impression of it when I
saw it was that it is sort of like a
Flipboard style experience for your news
feeds yeah so it basically pulls in like
updates and photos no video posea right
correct and there's how they gonna do or
what about Instagram are they going to
do any of that integration oh instagram
the hardware the HTC first i believe it
comes with instagram pre-installed so
easy you know integration between the
two okay but the photos don't show up in
the in the stream yet it's just facebook
facebook yeah yeah the facebook posts
facebook photos that sort of stuff okay
yeah and it also makes chat much easier
so it's got this thing called chat heads
which is kind of a ridiculous name to
total true yeah yeah I mean it's
Facebook and then a chat head is like
the this circular like icon the circular
avatar that's take
from your profile picture which is a
photo of your face but it's called a
chat head anyways and so it's just you
can start chatting with people over
facebook message or through text
messages and you can chat with them
without actually leaving whatever app
you're in at the time so it just kind of
goes over I think your app experience I
think it's pretty smart because it
consolidates all the different
conversations that you're having all the
different activities that one person is
participating in on your phone under one
person's profile instead of under a
bunch of different apps like right now
your notifications will say you got a
text message in this person this person
uploaded a photo and this person posted
a status update and you'll get those as
separate notifications now it'll just
show Christina and then we'll show all
of Christina's activity yeah next year
childhood yes yes yes oh suck was all
talking about how they're kind of taking
the app out of the experience it's all
about people now yeah goes along with
that yeah we've heard that before yes
yeah um there's also something
interesting that it consolidates
messaging from text messages and
Facebook messages under one sort of roof
in the chat experience which is much
like we see with iOS yeah I message so
green and blue on the iphone so it's
cool it's sort of it's a good trend I
think yeah it's easier to manage
conversations when you don't really care
where they're coming from yeah but who
you're actually talking to speaking of
iOS as our apple reporter do you foresee
this Facebook home arriving on an Apple
device anytime soon um suck said that
they have a good relationship with Apple
um you know I don't see why I don't say
I don't really see this happening at
least in I mean Facebook is already
integrated into the into the OS um you
know you log in with your you know
credentials you can share stuff it to
Facebook very easily I don't see Apple
wanting facebook to take control of its
operating system experience like yeah
this because that's I think most
important thing about home is that it
basically turns your
own into a facebook experience at the
top level so everything you do right
when you turn your phone on you start
interacting with it is a facebook
experience it's not an Android
experience which is kind of interesting
yes I mean this sort of i think opens a
door to other big brands being able to
make a facebook or sorry an android skin
that is all about them yes you know yeah
can't wait for my ebay phone right
amazon phone oh yeah I guess have been
rumors about that anyway I want I want
an Etsy phone well you know it is pretty
similar what to what the kindle fire
does definitely enjoyed you know so it's
uh it's not entirely unique but it's
also very very new and interesting yes
and it's not just so i guess now we can
switch and talk hardware yeah so you'll
be able to one more thing about facebook
home is that you'd be able to put it on
your phone if you have a galaxy s3
galaxy s4 and HTC one HTC one x HTC One
X members of One x+ yeah M or the new
HTC first on April 12 and you can
download it from the Play Store so since
it's not actually a version of Android
facebook is going to be able to update
this as many times as they want like a
nap so that's awesome news because that
is one of the big pain points in Android
is update times and they have committed
to updating it once a month yes I
believe every third Friday that's what
they said yeah okay we'll see so what
about the first yes so the first is
basically um it's not an early adopter
phone it doesn't have really amazing
specs it's just kind of at least to me
kind of a generic android phone its kind
of mediocre back nama but it's uh yeah
but you know it's you know just an easy
portal to your facebook experience if
it's your first smartphone it's just you
know something very powerful it will
work fine um I have a feeling that's
gonna sell kind of like hot cakes really
well it's a hundred bucks ivy TT yes
right which is awesome because people
are always like looking to save fifty or
a hundred dollars on a phone even though
I think
from the odd personally I would never do
that but there's a lot of people out
there to really want to do that right
also it's very very familiar so people
who may be afraid about you know boom
the android or they really like the
iphone this is just facebook and they
know Facebook and they feel okay about
hanging out in facebook right and the
moment they turn on their phone because
that's what they do anyway mm-hmm so I
think for those people I mean this is
it's like kind of a no-brainer yeah yeah
just live in your facebook experience
and now it's in your hand all the time
instead of just uh you know on the
computer so that's also going to be
available in April later on I think in
as the 12th also i believe they say yeah
okay and you can test it out if you have
one of the supported devices on the 12th
in the google play store and we're also
going to have a lot more coverage we're
going to have more videos from the event
that the announcement happened this week
at facebook headquarters and we have
reporters there which is why we're
talking about it not them because
they're still down there and we're going
to be having the devices in we're going
to review it so you can read about that
on wired also be sure not to miss
Stephen levees exclusive interview with
Mark Zuckerberg that is up on wired
right now you can click on that and read
it yeah anything else you know got the
home about the home it's it's you know I
have privacy issues with this phone it's
going to know everything about you it's
going to know who your talking with all
the time who your messaging where you
are when you are awake when you're
sleeping I'm personally like kind of
worried about Facebook knowing all of
that details about my life are you
worried about Google or Apple knowing
all those details about your life or
Microsoft because I would argue that I
probably should go those things yeah I
mean I probably should be but for some
reason I just don't maybe I feel that I
trust Apple a little bit more first
whether or not that's legitimate in any
way shape or form but I just you know
well Who am I to say whether it is it is
legitimate
I hope it's up to you to decide yeah
it's up to you to say how much you want
to trust these companies but it is very
very valid mm-hmm it's very valid yeah
location data what you want to print a
toothpaste you're using to brush your
teeth ma you know it really phones you
know just about any smartphone if you
want to you can turn on the camera and
turn on the turn on the microphone
remotely and start listening in and
watching people's lives yeah creepy I
mean you can go as deep as you want down
that rabbit hole meanwhile i'm just
going to be double tapping on all your
pictures of liking all excellent so like
us on facebook we'll see you next week